Claude Opus 4.6 just dropped and it
changed the AI agent game again because
16 Claude Opus 4.6 agents just coded and
set the record for [snorts] the length
of time that an AI agent has coded
autonomously. They coded for two weeks
straight. No human writing the code and
they delivered a fully functional C
compiler. For for reference, that is
over a 100,000 lines of code in Rust. It
can build the Linux kernel on three
different architectures. It passes 99%
of a special quote torture test suite
developed for compilers. It compiles
Postgress. It compiles a bunch of other
things. And it cost only $20,000 to
build, which sounds like a lot for you
and me, but it's not a lot if you're
thinking about how much human equivalent
work it would cost to write a new
compiler. I keep saying we're moving
fast, and it's even hard for me to keep
up. A year ago, autonomous AI coding
could top out at barely 30 minutes
before the model lost the thread. Barely
30 minutes. And now we're at 2 weeks.
Just last summer, Rock 10 got 7 hours
out of Claude and everybody thought it
was incredible. 30 minutes to 2 weeks in
12 months. That is not a trend line.
That is a phase change. The entire world
is shifting. Even one of the anthropic
researchers involved in the project
admitted what we're all thinking. I did
not expect this to be anywhere near
possible so early in 2026. Opus 4.6
shipped on February 5th. It has been
just over a week. And the version of
cutting edge that existed in January,
just a few weeks ago, that already feels
like a lifetime ago. Here's how fast
things are changing. Just in Anthropic's
own road map, Opus 4.5, shipped in
November of 2025, just a couple of
months ago. It was Anthropic's most
capable model at the time. It was good
on reasoning, good at code, reliable
against long documents. It was roughly
the state-of-the-art. Just a few months
later, Opus 4.6 6 shipped with a 5x
expansion in the context window versus
Opus 4.5. That means it went from
200,000 tokens to a million. Opus 4.6
shipped with the ability to hold roughly
50,000 lines of code in a single context
session in in its head, so to speak, up
from 10,000 previously with Opus 4.5.
That is a 4x improvement in coder
document retrieval over just a couple of
months. The benchmarks measures are off
the charts. And you guys know I don't
pay a lot of attention to benchmarks,
but when you see something like nearly
doubled reasoning capacity on the ARC
AGI2 measure, you got to pay attention.
It shows you how fast things are moving,
even if you don't entirely buy the
benchmark itself. And Opus 4.6 adds a
new capability that did not exist at all
in January. Agent teams. Multiple
instances of cloud code autonomously
working together as one with a lead
agent coordinating the work. specialist
handling subsystems and direct
peer-to-peer messaging between agents.
That's not a metaphor for collaboration.
That is automatic actual collaboration
between autonomous software agents in an
enterprise system. All of this in just a
couple of months. The pace of change in
AI is a phrase that people keep
repeating and they don't really
internalize what it means. This is what
it means. The tools that you mastered in
January are a different generation from
the tools that shipped this week. It's
not a minor update, people. It is an
entirely different generation. Your
January mental model of what AI can and
cannot do is already wrong. I was
texting with a friend just this past
week, and he was telling me about the
Rockin results in 7 hours. And I had to
tell him, I know you think you're up to
date, but the record is now 2 weeks. And
by the way, Rockuten using Opus 4.6 was
able to have the AI manage 50
developers. That is how fast we're
moving. that AI can boss 50 engineers
around. Now, the 5x context window is
the number anthropic put in the press
release. It's the wrong number to focus
on. The right number is a benchmark
originally developed by OpenAI called
the MRCV2
score. That sounds like a mouthful and
it's used to measure something that
matters enormously that nobody was
testing properly. Can a model retrieve
and use the information inside a long
context window? In other words, can you
find a needle in the haststack? It's not
about whether you can quote unquote put
a million tokens into the context
window. Every major model can accept big
context windows in January 2026. The
question is whether the model can find,
retrieve, and use what you put in there.
That is what matters. Sonnet 4.5, which
was a great model from Claude just a few
months ago, does have a million token
window, but the ability to find that
needle in the haststack was very low.
About one chance in five or 18.5%.
Gemini 3 Pro a little bit better at
finding that needle in the haststack
across its context window about one
chance in four 26.3%.
These were the best available in
January. They could hold your codebase.
They couldn't reliably read it. The
context window was like a filing cabinet
with no index. Documents went in, but
retrieving them was kind of a random
guess past the first quarter of the
content. Guess what? Guess what? Opus
4.6 six at a million tokens has a 76%
chance of finding that needle in the hay
stack. At 256,000 tokens or a quarter of
the context window, that rises to 93%.
That is the number that matters. That is
why 4.6 feels like such a giant leap.
It's not because of the benchmark score.
It's because there's a massive
difference between a model that can hold
50,000 lines of code and a model that
can hold them 50,000 lines of code and
know what's on every line all at the
same time. This is the difference
between a model that sees one file at a
time and a model that holds the entire
system in its head simultaneously. Every
import, every dependency, every
interaction between modules, all visible
at once. A senior engineer working on a
large codebase carries a mental model of
the whole system and they know that
changing the O module can break the
session handler. They know the rate
limiter shares state with the load
balancer. It's not because they looked
it up. It's because they've lived in the
code long enough that the architecture
becomes a matter of intuition, not a
matter of documentation. That holistic
awareness is often what separates a
senior engineer from a contractor
reading the codebase for the first time.
Opus 4.6 can do this for 50,000 lines of
code simultaneously. Not by summarizing,
not by searching and not with years of
experience. It just holds the entire
context and reasons across it the way a
human mind does with a system it knows
very very deeply. And because working
memory has improved this dramatically in
the span of just a couple of months,
it's actually not hard to see where the
trajectory is going to go from here. The
C compiler project 100,000 lines in Rust
did require 16 parallel agents precisely
because even a million token context
window can't hold that whole project at
once in its head. But at the current
rate of improvement, it won't require 16
agents for long. Let me tell you more
about the Rockuten story with the 50
developers. Now, Rocket is a Japanese
ecom and fintech conglomerate, and they
deployed clawed code across their
engineering org, not as a pilot, but in
production, handling real work and
touching real code that ships to real
users. Use Kaji, Rakuten's general
manager for AI, reported what happened
when they put Opus 4.6 on their issue
tracker. Clawed Opus 4.6 closed 13
issues itself. It assigned 12 issues to
the right team members across a team of
50 in a single day. It effectively
managed a 50 person org across six
separate code repositories and also knew
when to escalate to a human. It wasn't
that the AI helped the engineer close
the tickets. I want to be clear about
that. It closed issues autonomously. It
did the work of an individual
contributor engineer. It also routed
work correctly across a 50 person org.
The model understood not just the code
but the org chart. Which team owns which
repo? which engineer has context on
which subsystem, what closes versus what
needs to escalate. That's not just code
intelligence, that is management
intelligence. And a system that can
route engineering work correctly is a
system that understands organizational
dependencies the way a human lead
understands them. Which means the
coordination function that engineering
managers spend half their time on just
became automatable in a couple of
months. Think about the cost structure
that implies. A senior engineering
manager at a company like Rakuten might
cost a quarter million dollars a year
fully loaded, maybe more. A meaningful
part of their job, ticket triage, work
routing, dependency tracking, cross team
coordination. That is exactly what Opus
4.6 demonstrated it could handle. Not
the judgment calls about what to build
next, not the career development
conversation, and it wasn't done over
weeks and weeks and weeks, but the fact
that it can do operational coordination
that typically takes 15 to 20 hours a
week and demonstrated it could do it for
a full day, it shows you where things
are going. And the broader numbers tell
the same story. It is common now to see
hours and hours and hours of sustained
autonomous coding for individuals who
are playing with this. not in the
controlled enterprise environment even
people can kick off multi-hour long
coding sessions and just walk away and
do other things and come back and see
fully working software. That is no
longer an unusual thing in February
2026. And Rockwood isn't stopping here.
They're building an ambient agent that
breaks down complicated tasks into 24
parallel clawed code sessions. Each
single one handling a different slice of
their massive mono repo. A month of
human engineering is generating a
simultaneously running 24 agent stream
that helps them to build and catch
issues and that's in production. Now the
detail that gets buried under these big
numbers might be more interesting than
all of the numbers themselves because
non-technical employees at Rockoten are
able to use that system to contribute to
development through the cloud code
terminal interface. That is right. The
terminal is not just for engineers
anymore. People who have never written
code are able to ship features because
of the work Rockin has done to integrate
cloud code. So the boundary between
technical and non-technical, it keeps
breaking that down. The distinction that
has organized knowledge worker hiring
and compensation for 30 years is
dissolving in a matter of months. It's
not dissolving at the speed of your
ability to deploy a multi-month project
and is not dissolving at the speed it
takes to retrain humans. That is why
this is shocking. This is all happening
faster than we can adjust to it. One of
the features that is most hard for us to
wrap our minds around is the agent teams
feature that Opus 4.6 shipped. Tropic
calls them team swarms internally, which
is a little scary and I can see why the
marketing team changed that. But the
name is accurate. It's not a marketing
term. It's an architecture. Multiple
instances of clawed code are architected
to run simultaneously. Every single one
in its own context window. And they
coordinate through a shared task system
that has three simple states, right?
Pending, in progress, and incompleted.
Pending, in progress, and completed. One
instance of Cloud Code is going to act
as your lead developer. It will
decompose the project into work items
and assign them to specialists, track
dependencies, and unlock bottlenecks.
This is just like what Opus 4.6 did for
those 50 developers. The specialist
agents work independently, and when they
need something, they don't just go
through the lead, by the way. They can
message each other directly.
peer-to-peer coordination. It's not hub
and spoke. There's a front-end agent,
there's a back-end agent, there's a
testing agent. Effectively, they are
recreating the entire software
engineering org inside claude code team
swarms. And this is how that C compiler
got built. It's not one model doing
everything sequentially, right? It's 16
agents that worked in parallel. Some
building the parser, some building the
code generator, some building the
optimizer. And they all coordinated
through the same kinds of structures
that existing human engineering teams
use, except they work 24 hours a day.
They don't have standups, and they
resolve coordinations through direct
messaging rather than waiting for the
next sprint planning session. One of the
running questions in AI has been whether
agents will reinvent management. I think
this argues strongly that they did.
Curser's autonomous agent swarm
independently organized itself into
hierarchical structures and strong DM
published a production framework called
software factory that's built around
exactly the same hierarchical pattern.
And now anthropic has shipped a feature
with 13 distinct operations from
spawning managing to coordinating
agents. This is not really coincidence.
It's essentially convergent evolution in
AI. Hierarchy isn't a human
organizational choice imposed on systems
to ma imposed on systems to maintain
control. It's an emergent property of
coordinating multiple intelligent agents
on complicated tasks. Humans invented
management because management is what
intelligence does when it needs to
coordinate at scale. AI agents
effectively discovered the same thing
because the constraints are structural.
They're not cultural. You need someone
to track dependencies, right? You need
specialists. You need communication
channels. You need a shared
understanding of what has been done and
what hasn't yet been done. We did not
impose management on AI. AI effectively
discovered management and we helped to
build the structure and Opus 4.6 is the
first model that ships with the
infrastructure to run all of this as
just another feature. On the same day
Opus 4.6 launched, Enthropic published a
result that got much less attention than
that C compiler story, but it might
matter more in the long run. They gave
Opus 4.6 six basic tools, Python,
debuggers, fuzzers, and they pointed it
at an open-source codebase. There were
no specific vulnerability hunting
instructions. There were no curated
targets. This wasn't a fake test. They
just said, "Here's some tools. Here's
some code. Can you find the problems?"
It found over 500 previously unknown
high severity, what's called zeroday
vulnerabilities, which means fix it
right now. 500 in code that had been
reviewed by human security researchers
scanned by existing automated tools
deployed in production systems used by
millions of us. Code that the security
community had considered audited with
when traditional fuzzing by the way
fuzzing is the fancy technical word for
finding bugs and making sure you check
all the code. It's like fuzzing your
hand through the carpet and finding a
pin or something. And when manual
analysis failed, using a tool called
ghost script, which is what you use to
check these things, the model
independently decided to analyze it a
different way, going directly to the
project's git history. That's right. It
worked around obstacles and it read
through years of commit logs to
understand the codebase's evolution.
Nobody told it to do this. It just
decided to do it. And it identified
areas where security relevant changes
had been made hastily or incompletely
all on its own. It invented a detection
methodology that no one had told it to
use. It reasoned about the code's
history, not just about its current
state. And it used that understanding of
time to find vulnerabilities that static
analysis could not reach. Humans didn't
do this. This is why it found the bugs
it found. This is what happens when
reasoning meets working memory. The
model doesn't scan for known patterns
the way existing tools do. It builds a
mental model and I think that's the only
metaphor that works at this point of how
the code works, how data flows, where
trust boundaries exist, where
assumptions get made and where they
might break down. And then it probes the
weak spots with the creativity of a
researcher and the patience of a machine
that never gets tired of reading commit
logs. And I guarantee you, human
engineers get tired of that. The
security implications alone would
justify calling Opus 4.6 a generational
release. And yet again, I remind you,
it's only been a couple of months.
There'll be another one in a couple of
months. But this was not the headline
feature of Opus 4.6. As exciting as it
is, it wasn't even the second headline
feature. 500 zero days was the side
demonstration. That is the density of
capability improvement that has been
packed into a single model update
shipped on a Wednesday, February. Look,
there are skeptics for every release and
there were skeptics for 4.6 as well. And
the skepticism tracks historically. AI
benchmark improvements have
underdelivered before and repeatedly for
years. And that is why I don't depend a
lot on benchmarks. Sure enough, within
hours of launch, thread started to
appear on the cloud subreddit. Is Opus
4.6 labbotomized? Is it nerfed? The
pattern seems to repeat with every major
model release. Power users who have
fine-tuned their workflows for the
previous version discover the new
version handle certain tasks
differently. The Reddit consensus, for
what it's worth, has decided that 4.6
six is better at coding and worse at
writing. I haven't found that
personally, but dismissing it would also
probably be dishonest. Model releases
involve trade-offs. Model releases often
involve changes to the agent harness,
which is all of the system prompting
that the model makers put in that goes
around the deployment that they don't
talk about and they don't release. We
don't know how it changed. We feel the
change when we work with the system. So,
I'm sure it's possible that if you were
a Reddit user who was used to a special
prompt pattern that worked on Opus 4.5,
you might indeed be frustrated that that
pattern did not work on a much more
capable model overall. So, I get the
skepticism. I also get that people are
tired of hearing the world changing
every couple of months. It is exhausting
to keep up with. But that doesn't mean
it's not real. And that is part of why
I'm telling so many specific stories.
It's important not to just look at the
headlines. It's important not to look at
some number changing on some stupid
benchmark. It's important to hear the
stories of how AI is actually changing
in production now. So what does this
feel like if you are not an engineer?
What does this feel like if you don't
write code? Cuz the C compiler, let's be
honest, it's a developer story. The
benchmarks are developer metrics. But
the change underneath, what makes 4.6
special isn't about developers per se.
It's about what happens when AI can
sustain complicated work for hours and
days instead of minutes. Two CNBC
reporters, Dear Drabosa and Jasmine Woo,
they're not engineers, right? They're
reporters. They sat down with Claude
Co-work and they asked it to build them
a Monday.com replacement. That's the
project management tool, right? A
project management dashboard that had
calendar views. It had email
integration, task boards, team
coordination features. This is the
product that monday.com has spent years
and hundreds of millions of dollars
building. It s currently supports a $5
billion market cap for monday.com. It
took these reporters under an hour.
Total compute cost somewhere between $5
and $15. I hasten to add that is not the
same thing as rebuilding monday.com.
This was personal software. It's not
deployed. It's not for sale. It was just
for them. So yes, it is a big deal. Yes,
it is a generational change in our
ability for nontechnical people to make
software. No, I am not saying that dear
Drebosa and Jasmine Woo can refound
monday.com for $10. The real story is
that AI can build the tools you use, the
software you pay per seats for, the
dashboards your company spent 6 months
specking out with a vendor, an AI agent
can build a working version of that in
an afternoon, and you don't need to
write a line of code to make it happen.
Yes, it might just be for you. It's a
whole new category, people. It's called
personal software. It didn't exist just
a few months ago. It is now increasingly
easy to make that happen. Our daily
experience with AI is changing in ways
that are really difficult to benchmark,
but that doesn't mean that they're not
structural. A marketing ops team using
Claude Co-work can do content audits in
just a few minutes instead of hours and
hours. A finance analyst running due
diligence doesn't take a day to do it
because the model can read the document
set, identify the risks, and produce
lawyer ready redlines in just a few
minutes. Our rhythm of work is different
now. We can dispatch five different
tasks in a few minutes on Claude
Co-work. We can dispatch a PowerPoint
deck, a financial model, a research
synthesis, two data analyses, right?
walk away, you can grab a cup of coffee,
and you can come back and the
deliverables are just done. They're not
drafts anymore. It's just finished work.
It's mostly formatted, right? The
pattern that's emerging for
non-technical users is what anthropic
Scott White calls quote vibe working.
You describe the outcomes, not the
process. You don't you don't tell the AI
how to build the spreadsheet. You tell
it what the spreadsheet needs to show.
It figures out the formulas. It figures
out the formatting. It figures out the
data connections. The shift is coming
for all of us and it's going from
operating tools to directing agents. And
the skill that matters now is not
technical proficiency. It's clarity of
our intent. Knowing what you want, being
able to articulate the real requirement,
not just your surface request. That is
becoming the bottleneck. Ironically,
it's the same bottleneck the developers
are hitting, but from a different
direction. The C compiler agents didn't
need anyone to write code for them. They
needed someone to specify what a C
compiler means precisely enough that 16
agents could coordinate on building one.
The marketing team doesn't need someone
to operate their analytics platform
anymore. They need someone who knows
which metrics matter and can explain
why. The leverage across the board has
shifted from execution to judgment
across every function. Whether you write
code or not, if you lead an
organization, the number that should
restructure your planning isn't measured
in weeks or days. It's actually measured
in revenue per employee. Purser, the AI
coding tool hit $und00 million in annual
recurring revenue with about 20 people.
That's $5 million per employee.
Midjourney generated 200 million people.
Midjourney generated $200 million with
about 40 people. Lovable, the AI app
builder, they reached $200 million in 8
months with 15 people. For traditional
SAS companies, $300,000 in revenue per
employee is considered excellent and
$600,000 is considered elite. That would
be notion. AI native companies are
running at five to seven times that
number. Not because they found better
people necessarily, but because their
people orchestrate agents instead of
doing the execution themselves. McKenzie
published a framework not for others,
but for themselves last month. They're
targeting parody, matching the number of
AI agents at McKenzie to human workers
across the firm by the end of 2026. This
is the company that sells organizational
design to every Fortune 500 on Earth.
And they're saying the org chart is
about to flip. The pattern is visible at
startups, too. Jacob Bank.
The pattern is visible at startups, too.
Jacob Bank runs a million-doll marketing
operation with zero employees and
roughly 40 AI agents. Micro One conducts
3,000 AI powered interviews every single
day, handled at a tiny fraction of the
headcount that enterprise recruiting
firms need floors of people to do. Three
developers in London built a complete
business banking platform in 6 months. A
project that would have required 20
engineers in 18 months before AI.
Amazon's famous two pizza team formula,
the idea that no team should be larger
than what two pizzas can feed, is
evolving into something even smaller.
The emerging model at startups is now
two to three humans plus a fleet of
specialized agents all organized not by
function but by outcome. The humans
regardless of what their job title says
and it increasingly doesn't matter set
direction, evaluate quality and make
judgment calls. The agents execute,
coordinate, and scale. The org chart
stops being a hierarchy of people and it
becomes a map of human agent teams each
owning a complete workflow end to end.
For leaders, this changes the
fundamental equation we've been working
with for a long time. It's not about how
many people do we need to hire now. It's
about how many agents per person is the
right ratio and what does each person
need to be really excellent at to make
that ratio work. The answer to the
second question is really the same thing
that's distinguished really excellent
people for a long time in software. It's
great judgment. It's what we call taste,
which is vague, but typically means
deeply understanding what the customer
wants and being able to build it. It's
about domain expertise. It's the about
the ability to know whether the output
is actually really, really good. And
those skills now have 100 orex leverage
because they are multiplied by the
number of agents that person can direct
and drive against. out. Daario Amade,
anthropic CEO, has set the odds on a
billion dollar solo founded company
emerging by the end of 2026 at between
70 and 80%. Think about it. He thinks
there's a 75% chance that there will be
a billion dollar solo founded company by
the end of this year. Sam Alman
apparently has a betting pool among tech
CEOs on the exact same question. Now,
whether or not you believe that version,
the direction is undeniable. The
relationship between headcount and
output is broken. And the organizations
that figure out the new ratio first are
going to outrun everybody who is still
assuming they need dozens of developers
to do one major software project. If you
follow the trajectory that Opus 4.6 set,
by 2026, June, July, August, somewhere
in there, I would expect agents working
autonomously for weeks to become routine
rather than remarkable. By the end of
the year, we are likely to see agents
building full applications over
potentially a month or more at a time.
Not toy applications, real production
systems with real architecture decisions
complete with security reviews, with
test suites, with documentation, all
handled by agent teams. The trajectory
from hours to two weeks took just 3
months. The trajectory from two weeks to
months, that's coming soon. And the
inference demand that this generates
agents consuming tokens continuously
around the clock across thousands of
parallel sessions. Companies are not
ready for this. This is what makes the
$650 billion in hypers scale
infrastructure look conservative rather
than insane. Those data centers are not
being built for chatbots people. They're
being built for agent swarms running at
a scale that people have had difficulty
modeling or wrapping their heads around.
Opus 4.6 gives us a sense of that
future. So, what can you do about it? If
you're sitting here thinking, "Oh my
gosh, this is too much. It is coming too
fast." You're not alone. You're not
alone. You can do this. If you write
code, try running a multi- aent session
on real work, not a toy problem, a piece
of your codebase with real technical
depth. Watch how the agents coordinate.
That experience is going to change your
mental model of what agents can do in a
way that matters much more than anything
else. Because increasingly the way we
work is the bottleneck for AI. If we
want to go faster and build more, if we
want to feel like we have the ability to
do production work at the speed that AI
demands because increasingly that's what
they're going to expect from humans. I
got to say, if we want to be ready for
the future, best way we can do it is to
change our mental models. If you don't
write code, open up Claude Co-work.
handed a task you've been
procrastinating on that's that's felt
really hard, right? A competitive
analysis task, maybe a financial model
task, a content audit across last
quarter's output. Just describe the
outcome you want, not the steps to get
there. See what comes back. The gap
between what you expect and what you get
is the gap between your current mental
model and where the tools are today. And
for managers, look honestly at the 20
hours a week your team spends on
operational coordination, ticket
routing, dependency tracking. ask how
many of those hours really require
excellent human judgment and which are
just pattern matching because I got to
say your AI can probably take over a lot
of the coordination work already and if
you run an organization if you're on the
senior leadership team you got to
understand the question for your org has
changed it's not about should we adopt
AI or even which teams adopt it first
it's really what is our agentto human
ratio and what does each human need to
be excellent at to make that ratio work
and how do We support our humans to get
there. The people working in knowledge
work desperately need their leaders to
understand that humans need a ton of
support to get through this change
management and become a new kind of
worker that partners with AI. That is
not an easy thing and most orgs are
underinvesting in their people. I tell
people in AI that if you are on the
cutting edge of AI, it feels like you're
time traveling always because you look
at what's happening around you and then
you go and you talk to people who
haven't heard about it and they look at
you like you're crazy. They say, "No,
you can't do that. You can't run 16
agents at a time and run a Rust
compiler. What do you mean?" And AI can
manage 50 people. And when you tell them
that's just a Wednesday in February and
more is coming soon, then they really
roll their eyes. But welcome to
February. This is where we are. AI
agents can build production grade
compilers in just two weeks. They manage
engineering orgs autonomously. They can
discover hundreds of security
vulnerabilities that human researchers
missed. They can build your competitor's
product in an hour for the cost of your
lunch. They can coordinate in teams,
resolve conflicts, and deliver at a
level that did not exist 8 weeks ago.
None of this was possible in January.
And we don't know where this stops. We
just know it's going faster. That's the
tension underneath all of the benchmark
scores, all the deployment numbers. The
fact is the agents are here, they work,
and it's just getting faster from here.
And we're not sure what happens next.
The question I have for all of us is how
do we do a better job supporting each
other in adjusting to what feels like a
race out of MadMax some days? Welcome to
February. It's moving fast. If you're a
people leader, you need to take time to
think about how to support your people
to make it through this transition. If
you are an individual contributor or a
manager, I am putting as many tools as I
can up on the Substack to help you get
through this. But the best thing you can
do, it's not about the Substack. I don't
care. It's about you touching the AI and
getting hands-on and actually building
or trying to build with an AI agent
system that launched not in January, not
in December, but in February. And you
need to take that mindset forward every
single month. In March, you should be
touching an AI system that was built in
March. Every month now matters. Make
sure that you don't miss it because our
future as knowledge workers increasingly
depends on our ability to keep the pace
and work with AI agents.